we want to return to those startling
revelations by cassidy hutchinson during
the january 6 committee hearing
yesterday former trump white house
acting chief of staff mick mulvaney
called the testimony quote
explosive mulvaney is a cbs news
contributor and he joins us now good
morning sir
morning glad
you worked with cassidy hutchinson and
you said you found her testimony
eminently credible in fact you tweeted
about this in a tweet you wrote i don't
think she is lying why did you write
that
because i don't think she's lying i
thought her testimony yesterday was was
very compelling and very credible we are
hearing this morning that the u.s secret
service is pushing back on one of her
allegations regarding the
assault inside the limousine after the
rally but that's how these hearings are
supposed to work if she said something
that was wrong we would expect people to
show up and testify to that fact by the
same token if she said things that were
right we'd like to have people come up
and corroborate i think one of the
takeaways from yesterday is that it's
almost almost guaranteed now that mark
meadows will have to come and testify he
may take the fifth but my guess is he
has to show up someone from the trump
team
should show up and say that what she
said is wrong if what she said yesterday
is wrong it'll be interesting to see if
that happens
so sir you've been watching these
hearings uh of course die hard trump
supporters are pushing back on ms
hutchinson but do you think that these
hearings are changing mainstream
republicans perhaps republicans like
yourself about their attitudes regarding
the former president
sure it certainly changed my mind
yesterday's testimony did i've been
defending the president against the
charges of incitement to riot i've seen
the same speech he's given dozens of
times i've seen him accused of trying to
foment violence with with no violence at
all coming as a result so i've been
defending him but after yesterday when
she testified that he knew that there
were guns on property and that he still
encouraged people to go down to the
capitol that certainly changes my mind
whether or not it's going to change the
the hardcore maga supporters on on the
right wing of the party i don't know
that remains to be seen my guess is it
might not but i do think a lot of people
are looking at this entire hearing
process and january 6th differently
after yesterday's hearing
so if donald trump is the republican
nominee in the next presidential
election would you vote for him
yeah i think that's one of the really
good questions that come out of this is
that i think we've all assumed that
donald trump is going to clear the field
and run unopposed in a primary i think
one of the immediate outcomes of this
you asked about the impact on the
electorate i think there's a definite
impact on the field of people who might
run against him i think one of the
outcomes of yesterday is that mike pence
is going to look much more hard at
running in 2024 maybe ron desantis tim
scott i'm sure nikki haley was on the
phone yesterday saying can i run for
president maybe mike pompeo i think that
the field of 2024 candidates in the
republican party got a lot bigger
yesterday
but yes or no sir if he runs again would
you vote for him oh i i count me amongst
one of the republicans that hopes he's
not the nominee at this point
all right uh really quickly you also
said that uh in an op-ed for the
usa today that any way you slice it it
is obstruction of justice talking about
the evidence that the committee has
against people who tried to intimidate
witnesses
yeah i think that was the most stunning
part of the hearing that didn't get as
much attention as i thought that it
would i think the reason that liz cheney
held it towards the end was that she
thinks it's very important and if they
have hard evidence of people within the
trump world reaching out to witnesses to
point out that oh the president's
watching the president reads transcripts
as long as you do the right thing you'll
be in his good graces implying that they
won't be if they don't
that is problematic it's the so often in
our history um especially in political
history it's not the crime it's the
cover-up that ultimately gets people in
trouble and if the commission has real
evidence of that that's a whole new
matter that we just discovered for the
first time yesterday that could be a
problem for the former president and or
his team
especially as you say sir if mr meadows
does agree to testify mick mulvaney
thank you very much sir we appreciate it
thank you